und den prozess in magdeburg verfolgt
für uns jörg völkerling jörg wie hat ein
ballett sein unpassendes grinsen erklärt
er hat gesagt er habe das video heute
erst zum zweiten mal gesehen das erste
mal bei seiner vernehmung in karlsruhe
und er habe einfach sich amüsiert über
einige dämliche witze die ihr gerissen
habe wie zum beispiel den satz im video
niemand erwartet die internet ss er hat
weiter geschildert dass er letztlich
durch die tat durch das video durch die
verbreitung des videos die moral seiner
mitstreiter stärken wollte und dass er
auch zeigen wollte das einfach auch
improvisierte waffen etwas anrichten
können erst zum schluss sei es ihm um
die tat selber gegangen
und wie haben die anbieten überlebenden
auf diese schau dir da gemacht hat
reagiert wir haben mit christina feist
gesprochen dass seine junge wienerinnen
die an neunter oktober 2009 10 in der
synagoge in halle zu besuch war
sie hat uns geschildert dass sie das
video bis heute nicht angesehen habe
ganz bewusst sie habe ihm heute zeigen
wollen dass sie stark ist dass sie
überlebt hat
sie hat all diese schrecklichen szenen
über sich ergehen lassen und kurz bevor
die richterin dann eine verschnaufpause
gemacht hat hat sie den saal verlassen
ist hinausgegangen auf einer empore und
dort lag sie dann in den armen eines sie
begleitenden rabbiner der jüdischen
gemeinde dresden der sie getröstet hat
sie findet auch trost in einem anhänger
einer kette die sie uns gezeigt hat mit
dem jüdischen symbol für leben das ihr
am tag nach der tat geschenkt wurde und
seitdem immer begleitet und die anwälte
der nebenklage haben basiert heute
scharf befragt wie es er damit
umgegangen wie ein bockiges kind das auf
stampft wenn ihm etwas nicht passt er
hat versucht zunächst noch die fragen
ins lächerliche zu ziehen
er wurde gefragt was hat er aus der tat
gelernt da sagt er habe gelernt dass
seine maschinenpistole ein mündungsfeuer
von 351 metern pro sekunde habe er wurde
weiter gefragt welches verhältnis er zum
nationalsozialismus habe aber da sagt er
er habe kein verhältnis herberg eine
freundin
dann war das fragerecht an der anwältin
asiatinnen aus berlin
die konfrontierte er mit ihrem nachnamen
sagt das sind doch jeden sie sagte
darauf das könnte auch nur der nachname
ihres ehemannes seien daraufhin variiert
dann sind sie eine kollaborateuren ihr
kollege alexander hofmann wollte dann
von ihm die passwörter für noch bis
heute verschlüsselte festplatten von ihm
haben sagte er
die gebe er ihm nicht in der wert jedoch
keine einzige frage mehr beantworten
trotzdem fragte hoffmann weiter und
wollte einfach wissen wen er denn
eigentlich schützt und daraufhin sagte
valier den doch interessanten satz er
wolle seine eigenen mitstreiter nicht
hinhängen und er wolle niemanden
belasten daraufhin hoffmann ja wen
konkret und da hatte pariert dann nur
gesagt er wisse ja nicht wie viel
internetanschlüsse es weltweit gebe